trop conséquences de cette guerre
interprète des programmes et opéra
annuler un programme entièrement
consacré à tchaïkovski annulé par
l'orchestré philharmonique de cardiff
des sanctions qui visent les
compositeurs et les artistes russes
elles sont jugés par beaucoup
inappropriée bonjour laurent bayle vous
êtes fondateur de la philharmonie de
paris vous avez aussi dirigé la cité de
la musique la salle pleyel où l'ircam
l'institut de recherche et de
coordination d'acoustique et de musique
et puis vous êtes l'auteur aujourd'hui
d'une vie musicale aux éditions odile
jacob merci d'être avec nous tout
d'abord que pensez vous c'est à lunesse
de ces annulations et des programmations
en cascade qui frappe les artistes
russes en france pathé gaumont a annulé
la projection du lac des cygnes par le
ballet du bolchoï dans les salles à
paris je pense que
la fermeté s'impose donc la ligne des
sanctions telle qu'elle est pratiquée
par le gouvernement et l'europe bien sûr
et une ligne forte qui s'impose après il
ya des questions d'équilibré voire
parfois de bon sens s'attaquer
tchaïkovski
chostakovitch et c'est une erreur totale
de ce ski dans un colloque en italie
c'est une erreur énorme mais comment on
peut s il est un artiste à la politique
de son gouvernement ou à une idéologie
si vous voulez bien sûr dans
l'imaginaire collectif quand on parle
d'art et de culture on a toujours une
idée de quelque chose qui tend vers
l'universel défend des valeurs
humanistes la réalité plus complexe
pourrait souligner que dans l'histoire
de l'art effectivement
la ligne antisémite a été défendue de
wagner céline malheureusement et on peut
aussi considérer que tantôt l'art
anticipé protège
picasso guernica
neruda par rapport au chili et tantôt
l'art est piégé dans des rapports de
force obligatoire mans l'art est inscrit
dans la société et donc on peut pas le
détacher tout à fait des notions
d'engagement mais en revanche on peut
réfléchir que des artistes qui
soutiennent un régime politique soit
sanctionné est une chose tout à fait
compréhensible que quelques institutions
russes
représentative du pouvoir en place et
des oligarques eux souhaitent également
taxées on peut le comprendre mais des
artistes qui ne se sont pas exprimés sur
le sujet parce qu'ils vivent en russie
contre edko la chanteuse anna netrebko
s'est encore compliquée parce qu'on lui
reproche d'avoir soutenu le régime
soviétique au moment de la crimée mais
il ya énormément d'artistes qui eux ne
se sont absolument pas prononcée parce
qu'ils ont leur famille en russie qu'ils
vivent eux mêmes en russie elle est donc
les instrumentaliser dans ses rapports
de force me paraît pas être aujourd'hui
la ligne la meilleure à suivre même au
regard de ce que nous défendons c'est à
dire l'arrêt de la guerre et le soutien
ils peuvent vous écrivez dans votre
ouvrage je cite la musique est
essentielle elle permet d'apprivoiser ce
qui nous est étranger elle encourage à
la fois à vivre ensemble et à exister
séparément la musique c'est à la fois
une identité culturelle et une
fraternité
alors est-ce qu'au contraire il faut pas
d'y favoriser la diffusion des cultures
elles partagent des créations mais bien
évidemment c'est la raison pour laquelle
je défends toujours les projets
artistiques qui met en perspective en
regard les différentes cultures c'est
vrai que si chacun se défend uniquement
son pays sa culture
moi le classique mois les musiques
populaires et autres effectivement après
on en arrive à une perte de sens la
culture la musique rassemble
parfois ce sont les usages de la société
qui divisait il faut pas confondre c'est
pas la musique la culture l'art qui est
entre guillemets le fautif c'est la
manipulation ou
l'absence de recul et de réflexion qui
peuvent conduire à ces mauvais usage la
démission du chef d'orchestre russe
tugan sokhiev de leur caisse du capitole
à toulouse qu'il dirigeait depuis 2003
est à la tête du bolchoï
c'est comme un drame à ce qu'il n'aurait
pas pu être évitée si il aurait pu très
certainement être évité notamment en
essayant
d'avoir avec tugan sokhiev non pas des
prises de position immédiate public mais
une espèce de capacité à dialoguer avec
lui personnellement pour voir comment
lui allait à terme se positionner donc
lui a considéré dans cette affaire que
on ne lui laissait pas le choix on lui
demandait de choisir entre deux cultures
je suis pour la paix mais en même temps
je
suis ami des musiciens français des
musiciens russes donc je démissionne des
deux côtés on peut comprendre sa
position
en même temps bien évidemment il ya un
problème derrière il dirige le bolchoï
le bolchoï représente une institution
importante officiels russes c'est ce qui
était visé derrière lui mais vous voyez
il demandait de se prononcer alors
qu'elle est directeur du capitole c'est
de mon point de vue un manque de
subtilité dans cette affaire pour le
moins et cela ne me paraît pas aller
dans le bon sens c'est passent de cette
manière là on peut tenir une ligne ferme
mais en même temps équilibrée par
rapport aux artistes et aux anars parce
qu'un jour il va bien falloir se
dialoguer avec le peuple russe on n'est
pas en guerre contre le peuple russe
mais contre un pouvoir place et pour
dialoguer on le fait à travers ses
artistes albis ça peuvent être perçus qu
est-ce que ces décisions ne peuvent être
perçue autrement par les russes comme
une agression et est-ce que ça va passer
ce boycott est ce que ça va pas au
contraire renforcer le sentiment
nationaliste c'est une question qui se
pose je pense que dans un certain nombre
de cas les russes les artistes russes la
communauté russe comprend tout à fait
les sanctions quand les artistes ont été
très proches du pouvoir pendant une
décennie et non dénoncés aucun acte de
ce pouvoir vous savez il ya consensus y
compris parmi les artistes russes
ensuite il ya ceux des artistes russes
qui vivent en europe peut s'exprimer
plus librement et ceux qui vivent en
russie ont une attitude partagée parce
que notamment ils veulent défendre leur
famille alors effectivement
si avec l'ensemble de ces artistes on a
une position agressive on empêche même
de les éloigner d'une certaine manière
de ce pouvoir russe et à terme de
l'isoler très rapidement à ce qu'il faut
pas au contraire favoriser des festivals
de musique qu'on inviterait des artistes
ukrainiens et russes pour interpréter
des grands auteurs cela oui attentif à
penser que je ne sois pas utopique si
c'est pour la led saint-pétersbourg par
exemple oui non quand faut-il que et les
artistes russes et les artistes
ukrainiens se retrouvent dans cette
plate forme là c'est ce qu'entend daniel
barenboim a voulu jouer wagner
en israël l'événement bien sûr nous a
fait beaucoup réfléchir mais disons
c'était quasiment impossible à faire
puisque il y avait une telle tension
tant avec le public qu'avec
une partie de la communauté des artistes
que la chose donné quasiment impossible
à mettre en oeuvre c'est ce que je
crains si aujourd'hui on dit un acte qui
symboliquement effectivement serait très
fort mais
en fait les conditions autour objective
ne seraient pas réunies voilà il faut
mesurer si les conditions le permettent
merci beaucoup lembeye d'être venu merci
à vous je rappelle votre livre à votre
ouvrage une vie musicale aux éditions
odile jacob merci à vous merci à vous